it's an early start and a long and
challenging road ahead the Palestine
Freedom of movement Marathon sets off
from bethlehem's major Square its start
and finish line
local media says it's attracted Runners
from over 90 countries many with a
message I'm here to support the the run
the freedom of movement which we I
personally believe in very much and want
to be in solidarity with the Palestinian
people
me and my family
paid and show what it means to run for
Palestine too many people have been
killed recently including innocent
youths who had their lives ahead of them
Bethlehem is encircled by illegal
settlements the Israeli wall and
checkpoints it doesn't have the space
for a full Marathon course instead
Runners take two Loops the pass along
the occupation wall and two refugee
camps before turning back at an Israeli
checkpoint
and many have come to honor the memory
of Al Jazeera journalists Shireen Abu
akla who was killed last year by an
Israeli soldier with
she's reported on almost every Marathon
here since it was established in 2013.
I'm not so healthy and that's a healthy
year he's a journalist everyone knows
her everyone loves her in Palestine and
she was lovely
well aside from its markers of
occupation bethlehem's also known for
its Hills another challenge for the
runners before a well-deserved rest in
manger Square